Okay, sure, yeah, whatever. We need to be current.
What we need is hard, rock and hip, man.
Look at all these new bands now.
They don't have pyrotechnics.
They don't have sparks flying on the stage.
It's all tame!
We need to go to Coachella and rock.
Yes, yes!
And I agree a hundred percent.
By the way, it's called Nochella.
Though I could get us into Coachella.
All right, open killer song. You got it?
I think this is the stuff that inspired Kurt Cobain.
This is the most powerful pill
that you and your friend will ever take.
Feeling anything?
I'm good.
We're on a spiritual quest here.
We are this close to getting another shot.
You gotta focus if it kills you.
There are risks.
If you as much as hurt one fly, you'll
be cursed until the next sundown.
What was that?
It was an ant. A giant ant.
What are you doing with a gun?
I'm in the music industry.
That shit happens everyday in rock and roll!
Dude, you just fucked up.
I'm gonna make it rain blood.